hey everybody i'm kathryn mccor and i'm
so excited that we're here today because
this is pro
tips from pro chefs
[Music]
and i'm going to be sharing with you one
of the easiest
hacks that i have ever used that it's
all about
ramen and my kids go through ramen
so fast but i started to think like
ramen soup
every day it's kind of boring so we are
upping the ante and we are making stir
fried ramen tons of vegetables
tons of flavor and a few pro tips that i
can't wait to share with you guys
so we're going to start by getting my
pan over here
nice and warm because we're going to be
stir frying those vegetables
first pro tip and i'm just going to tell
you you can use any kind of vegetables
that you like
i love bell pepper to get in a little
bit of sweetness as our first vegetable
now i want you to see this
you know when you cut a bell pepper and
there's like seeds flying everywhere we
do not want that
we want to use it in a way that is
really simple
and easy and seed free so start by
chopping off the bottom flip it over
chop
the other side right off i usually give
these to my five-year-old and i'm like
here have a snack and then i take a
knife and we're just gonna
cut around the edges we do not want to
cut that white
pith so just make sure that white pith
stays intact
and voila look at that everything
we didn't waste any red or orange or
yellow or green or whatever bell pepper
you want
and then i just like to cut these into
some pieces you don't have to have too
much
but this is just a great way to have
your
ramen and get in some vegetables
too while that is heating this is going
to heat up really nice and fast let's do
this over some medium high heat because
we do want to like
keep the vegetables going so just going
to put in a little bit of oil
you can use any kind you like i've been
really just loving avocado oil lately
all right so get in a few of the
vegetables let's talk about
what i got here today so i've got some
onions i'm going to go ahead and put
those in
i hear that little sizzle that's what we
want that's when you know your oil
is at the perfect temperature and look
we're not even using that much oil
one to two tablespoons not a big deal to
get those onions and we're going to let
those cook
you know for about a minute minute i
like to when i cook with onions and
peppers i like to
put them in for about a minute more than
my other vegetables so just get those in
let's talk about our friend mr
ramen this is actually chicken ramen i'm
gonna make this a vegetarian dish
so open your little ramen
up and there's three things usually
inside sometimes two sometimes three
depending on it
and by the way also super affordable
this dish
is like grab any vegetable leftover
vegetables you've got
in your refrigerator in your pantry so
what i did was i already
took some of the noodles out of mine
covered them with water for about five
minutes three ways to do this you can
take your hot water spigot if you've got
one of those
you could do a pot of boiling water and
just pour it over
a kettle whatever you've got or take
cold water
cover your noodles put it in the
microwave and put them in for about
two minutes and then this is what we've
got
look at that soft silky
gorgeous noodles now don't throw away
that water though because
we're going to be using it in our dish
when you have
this like starchy water it's beautiful
it's like a natural
thickener and that's what we want to do
in here we're not going to be using all
the water but just enough
to make this sort of kind of glaze it's
a sticky situation
shitake mushrooms we love
mushrooms in our house so i just put cut
these in half let me show you another
pro tip here
so you've got your beautiful shiitake
mushroom just pull
out that stem it comes right out really
really nutritious
one of the best cancer-fighting foods
that you could possibly eat or mushrooms
and then sugar snaps just take your
sugar snap like that pull it
snap and pull it okay and then we're
just gonna cut these
um into you know like two or like pieces
like two three pieces you could also use
snow peas
uh lots of different vegetables you
don't want to overcook these though
sugar snaps they're like you want to
keep that like
that integrity that crunchiness um that
they offer and again they're so
so deliciously sweet all right just keep
this
moving let me get my tongs and again
like i love this because we don't need
too much
equipment we just got one pan here
that's going to do all the
do the job this is great for like lunch
a big dinner
i would say that if you're going to
serve this for four people you could do
to two ramen so again super super
affordable and efficient got that going
we're going to put in our sugar snaps
this is where we get into the really fun
stuff our flavorings
i'm that person that says you should be
improvising on your recipes do not feel
like you need to be married
to everything in here you could also add
some garlic you could
grate some fresh ginger but if you are
not eating
miso regularly you're not living it is
so much umami delicious flavor i like to
use a white or a yellow miso when i do
this dish
so what we're going to do is put about a
tablespoon
or more that's just me put it right in
okay and then we're gonna put in some
soy sauce
you could use shoyu you can use coconut
amino acids
i like to make sure i use low sodium soy
sauce though and then just put that
right in the middle oh
it smells so good now remember i was
talking about the water that we wanted
to save it
this is the moment why because miso is
very
thick and we want to thin it out a
little bit so we're just going to put in
a little bit of that water
it's going to mix up with that miso and
it's going to become this just like
beautiful paste
so go ahead and just take the back of
your spoon
let me show you i want to see how you
guys can really see this
just take the back of your spoon and
really like
melt that miso right in there and our
the water is gonna help to kind of
emulsify
it then we're just gonna take our fork
get our noodles
because we just want oodles and oodles
and oodles of noodles in here
now this is the time when you have about
a minute left
take your spinach because all we want it
to do is wilt and like i said any of
those greens don't miss a single one
now i'm going to take one last step in
this
we're going to go back to our seasoning
packet if you want to use the seasoning
packet
go for it but you know what i love the
sesame oil this is like
the liquid gold in our ramen and we're
just going to pour that all
on it's just going to give this like
beautiful flavor
um nice and rich that's what sesame oil
obviously
you know sesame also has a lot of
calcium did you see how
fast that was i mean this is talk about
something that literally takes minutes
um and again like it's the best use of
whatever you've already got
look at this isn't it gorgeous
so satisfying
and now let's do some sesame seeds right
on top
just to kiss it all over
oh look how easy that is lunch or dinner
so simple tons and tons of flavor i want
to see you make it and share it on
social media
make sure to tag me at welicious or at
one potato box
and of course at drew barrymore show
hashtag
drew barrymore show
[Music]